everyday I get on the internet
and I see another mediocre man with podcast who hates women
talking about the state of dating in the world
talking about how women are gold diggers or they're living in their masculine
they're never gonna have children
and that basically women have ruined dating a marriage
and as an outsider someone who is married
I really only hear one thing
men created the currency at the dating market
now they don't like the exchange rate
because being a financial provider was much more important
when women weren't allowed to provide for themselves
because when those were the terms
women were valued for their beauty and fertility
and men were valued for their status and money
and in some ways these are still the terms
women are absolutely still judged for their physical appearance
in ways that men are not however
women now have the opportunity and ability to provide for themselves
so if beauty and money are the two currencies of the dating marketplace
and women can provide both for themselves
where men cannot provide female company of fertility to themselves
the supply and demand and the exchange rate has shifted
and when you factor in the way the economy has been going
fewer and fewer men are able to even do the provider role
so their stock is down and someone gave them a microphone